WE GO TO OUR NEXT GAME,
PINTS!
>> HERE'S A LITTLE NEWS
SCOOP FOR YOU. BEN AND JERRY,
THE ERNIE AND BERT OF
LACTOSE, ARE CHANGING THE
NAME OF THEIR CHOCOLATE CHIP
COOKIE DOUGH FLAVOR TO I
DOUGH, I DOUGH TO COMMEMORATE
LAST WEEK'S HISTORIC SUPREME
COURT RULING ON GAY
MARRIAGE.
LEAVE IT TO THESE VERMONT
TRILLIONAIRES TO POKE FUN AT
AMERICA'S FESTERING CULTURAL
WOUNDS. COMEDIANS, WHAT ARE
OTHER FLAVORS BEN & JERRY COULD
RENAME TO REFLECT CURRENT
EVENTS?
I WILL PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK, AND BEGIN.
>> BILL COSBY'S GRAPE
ALLEGATIONS.
(APPLAUSE)
>> WHITE PRIVILEGE VANILLA.
>> YES, POINTS.
>> DONALD TRUMP'S RUM
RACIST.
>> POINTS.
>> RACHEL DOLEZAL'S VANILLA
BEAN.
(APPLAUSE)
>> SURPRISINGLY TASTES LIKE
CHOCOLATE, POINTS.
>> DOUG.
>> P. DIDDY'S KETTLEBELL
CRUNCH.
(APPLAUSE)
>> ZACK.
>> SCALIA'S EMPTY HEARTLESS
CORE.
>> IT'S ADAM & EVE NOT BEN &
JERRY.
>> POINTS.